[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
roger bennett broadcaster podcaster
filmmaker men and blazer co-host proud
american
and uh his memoir reborn in the usa an
englishman's love letter to his chosen
home now available online
and uh wherever books are sold although
raj
how english were you yesterday during
the euros
damn patrick i won't make it clear i
ride
with team america now you know the uh
it took me writing a book about how much
i love america for england to actually
throw off the shackles of self-loathing
self-sabotage and just 55 years of
crapping their pants in massive games
against germany
i feel a little bit like jonah and the
whale however i am genuinely happy
for that nation they have suffered in
lockdown and to watch
large men take off their shirts just let
it all hang out and suit themselves in
beer
my god they deserve it but if i had a
camera on you yesterday
watching england beat germany what would
i have seen
a large man with his shirt off
[Laughter]
i won't be clear when the united states
play england as they do in the women's
world cup where our women destroy the
english and alex morgan
knocks her head back and mimes drinking
tea i am like
yes in the face take that piers morgan
you bastard
um so that that is where my allegiances
are but you know my family
are all there i know the joy that it's
bringing them
i do know when you had an empire and you
no longer have an empire that leaves an
incredible vacuum
in that vacuum there's been dreams
shattered dreams
hopelessness self-loathing it's a little
bit
like the red sox 2004
dreaming over and over again sisyphus
pushing
the boulder up the hill only to have the
yankees knock it back down
what we saw yesterday was the english
breaking through
like the red sox but probably unlike the
red sox the english will now crap the
bed against ukraine in the next round
and find
a completely different way to torture
the nation but it is it's a lovely
moment and
if you are pro happiness which i like to
think i am
if you're pro-joy and if you are of a
belief
a lot of people think sports about
winning and their team if they win a
better people and if the team lose and
the
losers are worse people i don't believe
that i do believe
sports is human theater and i believe
that
it allows us to make incredible memories
that sustain us in time of light and in
time of darkness
and so i'm so happy for all of these
english
fans that they would they will they will
remember this day this
yesterday's joy the germans such a demon
in their minds they slayed the dragon
they caught the white whale and i'm so i
genuinely to be candid that i'm so happy
for them
when we acquired you what did we give up
in like was this uh just we just
acquired you your rights
from uh from liverpool i was a player to
be named later in the
uh in the revolutionary uh
i was just some scrub who could give a
couple of innings
um in in in pretty uh
light relief um what did you gain
uh by by adding me i mean i think that
and this is where i wrote the book
and we tried to give you madonna we
tried to give you courtney love
gwyneth paltrow we've tried to give you
some people you've got to keep your
voice down because madonna listens to
the show she actually does think she's
english
at this point in her life in her
biography it's funny her accent
changed immediately my accent i love
america i know i don't sound very
american but i love america like
you know kenny powers loves america and
the accent is the one thing that's not
true
i can't even i know on this show you
like make christian politics speak
english you make rebecca lo speak
america
can't do any of that like because i can
say like hooray for hollywood
and i can't say anything okay but how is
it that madonna goes to england
and then she acquires an accent in two
hours
well i can tell you how that works
because english managers english
football managers
famously steve mclaren who is a
character like a meme a human meme under
the manager
an english guy went to manage in holland
the netherlands
for a club team and like within two
press conferences
was like um yes uh it's a good
game to play today
another guy jerry barton he's from near
me liverpool he went to play in france
and he's
like again second press conference he's
like yeah i think he was
you know the win is important and what
i've learned
is hilarious it is hilarious to watch oh
my god
i mean western mckinney is an amazing
young guy a place for juventus a
powerhouse in italy
out of dallas texas and like his third
game i think
um he's like missed a a chance and he
runs off the goal and he's like
to the cameras
i think i think that the speech things i
have actually
i've wondered why do i not have an
american accent i think it's because
if you have a musical ear then and i
assume madonna
probably arguably may or may not have a
musical here but i'm assuming she does
uh you immediately change and adapt to
the voice around you i have no musically
i've been trying to learn the banjo for
about
uh for about the last 110 years going
nowhere with that and it's because i
don't have a musical ear and that's why
i still sound like this
but you asked me like to become american
that's why i wrote the book
is two of two of to have stood in
in a a courtroom in manhattan with 161
fellow new americans being sworn in with
the oath of allegiance
and you know america in times of wonder
american times of challenge
i will say i look left and right to be
in that courtroom
and to look at my fellow new americans
you know i'd escaped you know a couple
of football matches where the violence
went dodgy some chip shot beatings late
at night when the pub shut in england
these people had escaped civil war
unrest
famine i mean just the stories were
incredibly humanly touching and the one
thing that joined all of us in that room
was the power of the idea of america so
i think when you have
human beings like me you are adding
individuals who've dreamed about america
who've drawn strength from america in
dark times the idea of america courage
tenacity possibility and ultimately
that's what you add by adding me
another bald man who thinks he can
broadcast
but loves america in the face the
memoirs reborn in the usa an
englishman's love letter to his chosen
home we're talking to roger bennett the
broadcaster podcaster filmmaker mennon
blazer's
co-host your first
introduction to american sports was what
or who
chicago bears 1983
just starting to throw off the shackles
the nfl was broadcast for the first time
with a niche channel in england for an
hour
every week 14 games in those uh every
weekend in those days
and they crushed all 14 games down to a
highlight reel of one hour
i'd i've said a couple of times it's it
was all put to bonnie tyler's holding
out for a hero it was like tony dorsett
sweeping left it'll be
very dramatic remember english football
in those days was played by
angry men who wanted to kick anything on
the muddy pictures
be at the ball or their opponent and
then go off to the pub and have a
cigarette a pie in a pint
so like to see billy white shoes johnson
return a kickoff for 83 yards but he
only did it so that when he got there he
could just
unleash the funky chicken like 13 year
old me was like holy crap
joy wisdom wonder um you know to see new
orleans saints fans
under bum phillips first of all i was
like my god there's a man called bum
and then they were hooples they were
like owen 14 and again
in england if your team was losing that
much you would go to the games just to
fight your opponents fans and taste your
own blood in your mouth
but the new orleans saints fans they
were like we love this we're the new
orleans eights and they pulled on
paper bags over their heads and just had
a great time and i was like my lord
trying to
find joy even in defeat that is that is
a that's a wonderful way to live a life
but the chicago bears
i always my family left europe in the
early 1900s thinking they were headed to
chicago
so my family always in dark times and
there were many of them in liverpool in
the 1980s we'd all
be like we should have lived there we
should have lived there so to watch this
bears team walter payton
jim mcmahon william refrigerator perry
throw off the shackles of defeat
self-loathing and just a pathetic
franchise and say no we swagger we super
bowl shuffle
we dominate and we trash talk on our way
to victory
13 year old me was like you don't have
to be who you are you are not trapped by
history you can redefine yourself and it
was
thrilling on a sporting level and it
taught me life lessons on a personal
level then but do you have friends
growing up who look at you and say
like what are you doing like you you're
a traitor you left us behind like did
you get
like feedback blowback by becoming an
american citizen
um i shared this dream with another
friend of mine in liverpool we were
because the games were on the nfl games
and we knew they were being played a
week on television they were a week old
and there was no internet so me and my
friend jamie we would from his house not
mine because my dad would have killed me
we used to phone up random three one two
chicago
um numbers during bears games and people
were they hello
and we'd be like hey how are the bears
doing and they'll be like oh matsui's
just run for four yards
yeah now what's happening and they're
like jim mcmahon's dropped back oh he's
just
overthrown that one to willy goat and
we'd be like and we get them to give us
personal commentary and run up just
enormous
so i shared this stream with my best
friend and it's what the book's about
about loving you know everything heart
to heart fantasy island john hughes
movies run dmc the beastie boys
and miami vice came on our screens then
and watching don johnson um you know
just in his pastels in his t-shirt and
his
rolled-up sleeves and there's never any
socks and his
hair that became blonder with every
consecutive season of the show
gunning down narco threats in
espadrilles
i realized that to be willing in life to
succeed you have to have a singular
style
be stick with it and then see not care
about what anybody else says about you
and so that's what i took from miami
vice that was my attitude i didn't i
learned not to care
i also started to wear espadrilles with
no socks which were completely
impractical for liverpool
but um i've learned not to care about
what other people think though
it's like you were an american trapped
in an englishman's body
that is the opening paragraph of my book
i persuaded myself because my family
wanted a move there and ended up by
mistaking liverpool because my
great-grandfather he's down here
there he is god love him harris pollock
that's him in the russian army where he
had to serve for 25 years and then he
fled ukraine
and he was headed to chicago he was a
butcher he wanted to become a butcher in
the hog capital of the world
and the the myth of the liverpool jewish
community is that it's full of the
idiots who when
the boat dock to refuel in liverpool saw
the one tall building on the liverpool
skyline like we're in new york
let's go and so we got off and we're in
liverpool and local is the greatest city
in the world i won't be clear
but in the 80s as the north economically
politically culturally justice and
you've seen billy elliot you've seen the
mining
devastation the cotton the steel just
the post-industrial britain there was a
wasteland
and so i did i survived this very
dark black and white life by inhaling
american sports american culture and yes
damn
i tell myself at night i had the statue
of liberty painted on my bedroom wall
i would arrange my curtains so that the
light fell on her face and i'd persuade
myself that i
i was an american trapped in an
englishman's body even though i'd never
set foot in america
that's that's the story you tell
yourself to be able to get through
will the u.s men win a world cup in our
lifetime
yes yes if they um if
science allows us to live forever then
the answer is
i can tell you i can tell you ted
williams will definitely be alive
and walk in the earth by the time i
recommend
look if the american men
can become half as good as our women
they can be bloody bloody good
and the reality is i moved to america
and right before the last world cup and
on men in blazes we always joke sakura
america's sport of the future as it has
been since 1972
it's always meant to be the next big
thing that it was never an overnight
success it's been slow
and steady that there's a huge audience
consuming consuming the euros right now
and our men have gotten to it there's a
young
wave of incredible talent christian
politic i mentioned
weston mckinney i mean i mentioned tyler
adams
uh that there's a slew of the geo reign
are still these young stars and for the
first time
in your lifetime young stars are willing
to go abroad to play against the best
for the best they're not sticking around
in america anymore
there's a young wave of talent who will
make us very proud sooner than we think
is there somebody else in england we
should acquire
oh well we tried that with piers morgan
yeah we didn't we didn't
want him no we returned him we didn't
want him we got him
it didn't work very well i i think we i
we've got
we've got we've got i like our i like
our caster characters and it is
it is amazing in the past you know
america america did well by having air
bases in strategic footballing countries
germany and we'd we had a lot of dual
nationals
but the it's beckham ours
not really i don't think i think he's
got the english flag tattooed about 87
times on this person
that's just the ones we know about the
ones he keeps secret
we have no what about ed sheeran is is
ed sheeran ours now
why would you want ed sheeran when
you've got kevin harter who is
ed sheeran is just the poor man's red
velvet let's be candid
do you think kevin herder is just a
taller ed sheeran
with talent yeah and a better jumper i
actually i actually watched in the royal
box yesterday
um watching england and they showed the
beckham shot with shoe and my first
impulse was oh my god kevin hurst
god love him ginger power you go for it
jeff
nobody wants to sit next to beckham as
good looking as he is
um he gets better and better and better
looking that is the
the remarkable thing he is he is and
it's like ronaldo um
who cristiano ronaldo is like 35-36
and everyone's like oh this could be his
last big tournament do you think
ronaldo's had a little help
like ted williams help a little work a
little work done
um i think i've got to be candid ronaldo
seems to be learning lessons about life
his eyebrows he used to over pluck in a
devastating fashion
and he everyone thinks he's just about
himself that guy's clearly listening to
feedback because he's filling them out
i i i think he is gorgeous i am team
messi
just to be totally candid but you have
to admire this human being that is
driven by
a constant drive for self-improvement
and human wonder
i once stayed in his hotel room at the
euros
after portugal had been defeated um and
then i moved into the hotel when
portugal
left i was in donetsk in ukraine which i
would really recommend for americans or
looking to um
to travel to a off the uh off the road
tourist spectacle and i moved into his
hotel room they vacated maybe 12 hours
earlier
and all i will tell you for the next 11
days the drakon war cloud that still
hung to
me vicariously by moving in there was
was just immense and
i um i lived a tiny bit of his life
he is a gentleman that takes care of
himself in in wonderful ways and we
should all be so blessed to
i mean god look at me i'm in though
i'm in the position it's not commenting
i'm cristiano ronaldo
ah great to talk to you as always roger
thank you for joining us
thank you for having us on thank you
america and have a
have a great fourth of july oh mate this
is the book for it i'd never take
a single day in america for granted dan
thank you that's
uh roger bennett reborn in the usa an
englishman's love letter to his chosen
home